we just look at it as creatives and say
look at all of these things we can play
with when you're working on movies as
crazy as venom and its recent sequel of
course you're dealing with a whole lot
of cgi but did you know there are tricks
to making it look so sexy and smooth
let's take a look behind the vfx curtain
at let there be carnage
why do i even talk to you guys
everywhere else that story kills that's
the whole story yes
now that tom hardy's eddie brock and the
symbiote are more in sync and working as
venom this film freed up tom hardy to
really go nuts new director andy circus
wanted to give the actor the freedom to
move around without having to worry
about putting a man in a suit be it
mocap or monster on screen since venom
is coming out of hardy it made more
sense to have him skip the mocap and
layer the monstrous side of venom right
over the actor according to circus i've
spent a considerable amount of my life
playing a character with two sides to
his personality i knew that this film
would be about how to free up tom to
imagine venom's presence we knew it
would not be helpful for him to act
opposite a man in a suit because venom
is a symbiote coming out of him
we wanted to give tom the freedom in his
process to give the performance he
wanted hardy has also weighed in on this
decision saying in an interview for
total film that the decision to not
worry about mocap was an easy one given
the difference in height between himself
and venom as well as the extreme
flexibility of the creature's face and
limbs saying so the mocap treatment went
out the window pretty quickly facially
your eyes and teeth and tongue are not
going to match with this and you need a
seven foot tall basketball player in a
lycra suit for the physical shots how do
we you know
move this around not just necessarily
with uh
animation or cgi or motion capture but
as an actor
[Music]
you've got to be willing to look a
little nuts when you're pretending to be
a seven foot tall monster who eats
people's heads since the production
chose to have hardy physically on set
and doing stunt work for many of the
film's action sequences the actor had to
dig deep into his history of playing
tufts and heavies as well as his more
reactive animalistic performances like
max rokatanski in mad max fury road and
james cazaya delaney in taboo just in
case you know it's successful which you
hope it is and you put everything into
it
one of the biggest changes going into
venom 2 was the decision to replace
departing director ruben fleischer with
andy circus having made a name for
himself working with wetta to bring
characters like gollum king kong and the
planet of the apes is caesar to life
the guy is still the undisputed king of
detailed motion capture performances
even though the film shies away from
motion capture he was still an excellent
voice to have on set as he could help to
block out scenes and accommodate for the
height differences between his actors
and the creatures they were portraying
in fact circus received a call to
consult on the film though he didn't
know it at the time tom hardy gave
circus a call and said andy i'm going to
be doing this character and it's going
to be a digital character and i wondered
if i could come down to the imaginarium
which is a performance capture studio in
the uk but then circus didn't hear from
him again for a while and it wasn't
until venom came out that he realized
hardy was talking about venom he really
had to act in this movie he really is a
big
character one of the wildest things
about watching the new venom is checking
out woody harrelson as cletus cassidy as
cassidy harrelson is taking huge wild
swings to portray the serial killer
imbuing him with a larger-than-life
personality as he tears his way through
san francisco surfs on cars and
generally looks like he's having a blast
the whole time i just didn't feel like i
was free enough to be more creative
here's an incredible bit of stunt work
for you that motorcycle stunt where
eddie goes flying during a massive jump
well it turns out that it was really
mostly him the production set up the
jump and then put both the bike and
hardy on wires moving them together and
apart on a green screen and then adding
the cgi tendrils later
windows get smashed and motorbikes and
all kinds of things that happen
[Music]
one of the things that the sequel really
amps up from the first film is the
incredible dysfunctional domestic
relationship between eddie and the
symbiote treating them more like an old
married couple than a crime-fighting duo
this is on full glorious display during
the scene set in eddie's apartment where
the effects team connected props
furniture and sometimes whole actors to
cables so that the objects were moving
through a physical space and could be
embellished with venom's many cgi
tendrils later on and yes that includes
sonny and cher eddie and venom's pet
chickens who were played by live animals
there's an enormous amount of humor to
be had out of this entire scene
here's something that's sure to give you
flashbacks to playing racing games when
you were little apparently tom hardy has
a habit on set of making his own sound
effects when he was getting hit or
throwing punches and even as he was
getting his nose broken by the symbiote
something that puts him in the grand
tradition of actors who can't stop
making sounds on set like harrison ford
in the original star wars i take orders
from just one person me
sometimes there's not a whole lot to do
but fake an entire scene such as this
one where cletus cassidy transforms
fully into carnage background locations
props the monster even cassidy himself
were all rendered digitally giving us a
cool and gnarly look at the musculature
of a symbiote suit when it puts itself
together
[Music]
sometimes fate and timing are against
you and you have to make certain
concessions to the movie gods for
example this scene with cassidy in the
car was originally supposed to be filmed
as a larger stunt on location except
well a little movie called the matrix
resurrections was shooting in town at
the same time and they got the location
first instead the scene with the
suspended car was rigged against blue
screens and large projection screens to
recreate the city skyline you know
that's cool because i i sure enjoyed
playing them and i'm glad i got to do
this
there seems to be one little trick to
shooting an animation scene in a venom
movie all you do is attach a string or a
suspension harness to literally
everything in the shot and then you pull
and wiggle everything around like these
poor stunt guys in the scene where
carnage and cassidy escape from prison
as i walked around i felt like the king
of course it wouldn't be a movie
released in 2021 if we didn't talk about
a little bit of pandemic delay shooting
on the film finished early on but due to
release delays andy circus and his team
were blessed with a ton of extra time to
tweak the edit of the film and more
closely oversee the cgi work
it takes a lot to create truly
convincing cgi back in the days of black
and white films production designers had
to work carefully to pick outlandish
colors that would still pop together and
be distinguishable when reduced to a
grayscale but venom 2 is a testament to
the fact you still need to be careful to
create the illusion of this symbiote goo
actually coming out of the actors and
seeping through their clothes picking
placement and really reactive colors was
a must
finally here's a little bit of revenge
for you there are several large night
scenes in venom 2 where there are a
bunch of helicopters flying around in
the background they don't really impact
anything but they add a certain scope to
the scene so you might be forgiven for
thinking that they're cgi not true
though
they're actually helicopters that were
flying around a nearby location for the
shoot of
you guessed it the matrix resurrections
sweet free helicopters a film of this
scale this piece of ground entertainment
blockbuster material with a
predominantly black cast i mean it just
hasn't been done before say what you
want about tom hardy it takes a lot of
talent to be able to play off an
invisible alien that lives inside of you
you really have to be willing to get
weird to create good art sometimes what
cgi-less moment surprised you the most
let us know in the comments thanks for
watching